Сонцезахисні окуляри.
Шорти. Гаманці.
Сувенірна крамничка підприємства громадського
транспорту в Берліні пропонує товари на всі випадки життя.
Усі вони відрізняються чорно-червоно-синім
логотипом компанії - тим, що прикрашає також
сидіння вагонів берлінського метро.
Цей візерунок з’явився приблизно чверть століття тому.
У вагонах метро тоді змінили оббивку,
щоб захистити крісла від вандалізму.
На такому візерунку майже непомітні написи фломастером.
Останніми роками транспортне підприємство за
підтримки одного з провідних рекламних агентств
зробило з цього логотипа справжній культ.
Нині ж цей культ перетворився на хайп – у двох
магазинах Берліна у продаж надійшла лімітована
партія кросівок Адідас, яка не просто прикрашена
фірмовим візерунком з метро, а й водночас є річним
проїзним квитком на міський транспорт Берліна.
Випустили лише п’ятсот пар таких кросівок.
Охочі купити цей взуттєвий абонемент почали
ставати в чергу за чотири дні до старту продажу.
Навпроти магазину в районі Кройцберг
навіть з’явилося наметове містечко.
Це була важка ніч. Ішов дощ зі снігом. Усе було.
І тепер ми за кілька кроків від придбання.
Мені сподобалися ці кросівки через камуфляж.
Я люблю камуфляж. До того ж, річний
проїзний задешево – усього 180 євро на цілий рік!
Нині я плачу 64 євро на місяць.
Ажіотаж перевершив усі очікування організаторів акції.
Магазин заполонили оператори не лише німецьких,
але й світових телеканалів.
Керівництво транспортної компанії не приховує
свого задоволення від оригінального маркетингового ходу.
Ми дуже раді цьому. Це просто чудова комбінація
крута компанія міського транспорту з візерунком
крісел метро і, звісно, Адідас – провідна марка кросівок.
Це так незвичайно. Ніде в світі ще не було,
щоб такі два підприємства співпрацювали і виробляли кросівки.
Для компанії Адідас це також вкрай вдалий маркетинговий хід.
Цей хайп важко пояснити. Ми самі вражені.
Ми, звісно, здогадувалися, що ідея хороша.
Але чесно кажучи, ми не розраховували, що
це набуде таких масштабів.
Через величезний натовп на тротуарі
довелося викликати поліцію.
Перших покупців вітали аплодисментами.
До речі, кросівки вже перепродають в інтернеті.
Ми знайшли варіант за 1800 євро – це вдесятеро
дорожче початкової вартості.
Вшитий проїзний діє до кінця 2018 року.
Після чого кросівки перетворяться…просто на зручне взуття.